and i will be sending a letter to the  department of justice asking for a  criminal referral  because he has lied to congress this is  an absolutely  ghastly and dreadful direction  for the country to go in and it's a very  very dangerous one  dr peter hotes posted to his twitter  a link to an essay from 1941 by  waldemar campford called science in the  totalitarian state  and it reminds us that the targeting of  scientists and doctors has a really  ugly history in particular in the 20th  century  remember that albert einstein decided to  go to the u.s  at the very end of 1932 eventually came  to the united states in 1933 and stayed  because of what was happening in europe  including  with reference to the world of science  and  attacks on science are simply a  totalitarian hallmark